the new war is the latest and largest
cinematic story-based expansion for one
of the best free-to-play games out there
warframe and it's available today for
free on all platforms the new war
features a conflict that has been
brewing between the sentience and the
tenno for years and you'll be able to
fight in it using three new playable
characters old enemies come back new
enemies emerge and a new warframe will
join the ranks as well the game has been
updated with countless quality
improvements to make it more fun and
accessible this is the perfect moment to
get into warframe for the first time and
for previous children of the lotus to
come home to the game warframe is almost
9 years old but it's still in the top 15
games on steam warframe has a community
of more than 70 million registered
players worldwide and that's because the
developer digital extremes has spent
that time developing an epic personal
storyline and adding new content that
brings the space warriors out of the
confined spaceships and into large open
worlds it's been optimized for
solid-state drives and next-gen consoles
looks beautiful in 4k at 60fps and they
never stopped adding to the huge arsenal
of warframes weapons and mods which lets
you customize your play experience to
exactly what you want the warframe story
evolves with each update in an ever
expanding world of lore and rich
storytelling the critically acclaimed
campaign is now more than 30 hours long
and spans 13 cinematic quests the new
war expansion is the culmination of
years of in-game conflict and mystery
and its story will serve as the
foundation for the next chapter of
warframe it focuses on the interpersonal
relationship between the tenno and the
lotus who has been their mother figure
and it has some amazing gameplay
innovations that i won't spoil for you
here speaking of lore here's a quick
refresher a highly advanced race called
the oregon were running out of resources
in their solar system when they
discovered the void a plane of existence
with massive power that allowed for
travel to other distant solar systems
they sent the colony ship zaraman 10-0
through the void to establish a foothold
in a new system exposure to the void
though turned the adults on that ship
into murderous lunatics but it gave the
children strange powers these children
became known as the tenno after the ship
that carried them the oregon still low
on resources in their solar system
created a race of self-repairing robots
to brave the void they successfully made
it through and after a time in the new
system they actually developed sentience
rallied by their new leader hun how they
rebelled against the oregon who called
the robots they created the sentience it
was discovered by an oregon researcher
named margalist that the tenno's powers
allowed them to bond with the
biomechanical armor units called
warframes and they became the best and
only weapon the oricon had to combat the
sentience the war against the sentience
was one but the oregon now feared the
tenno and executed margolis for defying
their orders to destroy the warframes
the sentient leader hunhau also feared
the tenno and he sent his daughter nata
to destroy them but upon seeing that
they were children nataa betrayed her
father and became the lotus a mother and
protector to all tenno the oregon empire
fell to ruin with many warring factions
taking the place of the united whole
this conflict was known as the old war
in the new war the sentients have
returned and are launching a massive
invasion to conquer the origin system at
their head is hunhau's son era who paves
a path of destruction that pushes you to
explore new edges of the origin system
in an attempt to fight back the invading
force all the factions in the origin
system have to unite or suffer the same
fate as the oricon the new war brings
old enemies together to fight the
biggest threat in the galaxy don't be
afraid
the new war is promised to be the
biggest story-driven cinematic quest in
warframe history with massive missions
and hours of action-packed gameplay and
storytelling but there's a lot more
content coming in the new war than just
story for the first time you take on the
role of faction members you have up to
now largely only fought against which
adds exciting new ways to play you use
the heavy grineer military weapons as
clone soldier designated call 175 as the
corpus technician vessel you prefer to
take an indirect approach relying on
gadgets and drones rather than direct
conflict and when you play as the dax
elite guard named teshin you ninja
sprint directly into the sentient horde
sword slashing all of them fighting in a
war against the sentience and we get to
experience the war through their
individual character stories told from
their perspective
the destruction reaped on the origin
system by the sentient invasion will
change the world of warframe as we know
it in the tennocon trailer we saw what
they did to the town of cetus and that
was only the first attack so you can
expect to see a lot more destruction in
their path the sentients seem to have
taken over the design department at
digital extremes as well because the new
war update releases skins that reimagine
mesa and volt as if the sentients had
designed them and it unveils the first
of its kind protovir armor set which
actually evolves as you kill sentient
enemies until it unlocks its ultimate
form the new war introduces the 48th
warframe to join the ranks caliban is a
half sentient hybrid created by era who
does massive aoe damage with his scythe
made from a whim of a fallen idol on in
addition hero prime the enhanced and
elegant variant of warframe's fan
favorite dark priest will be released
with the new war alongside his signature
weapons and accessories the new war
promises to be the biggest and most
ambitious update in warframe history
with its epic new cinematic quest
playable new characters and warframes
and so much more one thing is for sure
whether you're brand new to the origin
system or returning to fight the
sentience there's never been a better
time to play warframe the new war is
available now on all platforms embark on
an all-out war against the sentience and
discover your power within by signing up
and playing for free today at
warframe.com